bonjour david alors la mobilisation est
manifestement au rang des essais
plusieurs milliers de personnes défilent
dans leur vie en direction de la place
de la république pour dénoncer cette loi
un climat les associations
environnementales à l'initiative de ce
rassemblement accuse emmanuel macron de
trahison un démocratique et réclame un
véritable projet de loi climatique et
qui la tiennent surtout ses engagements
vis-à-vis du contrat citoyen qu'il avait
un passé avec cette convention un
citoyen je me trouve justement avec l
faouzi lellouche l'une des figures et
des gilets jaunes venu apporter son
soutien à ce mouvement et surtout
rappeler une chose c'est que cette
convention citoyenne à la base elle est
à l'initiative de gilet jaune
effectivement lorsque priscilla ludo ski
et d'autres gilet jaune avait accompagné
au ministère de l'environnement de la
transition écologique et ben il avait
fait cette demande de pouvoir réunir des
assemblées citoyennes
concernant trois thèmes l'environnement
le social et l'économie emmanuel macron
bas a retenu on va dire que
l'environnement parce qu'ils voulaient
récupérer des voix et voyez que cette
tendance
eh bien en attendant aujourd'hui on est
venu dénoncer le fait simplement débat
qui n'a pas tenu son engagement et il ya
eu des vraies filtre parce que du coup
sur les 149 proposition de la
concertation citoyenne donc de simples
citoyens tirés au sort et ben il en a
respecté que 1/3 donc ça c'est pas
normal alors qu'il avait donné son
engagement comme quoi à qui
adopterait sans filtre toutes les
propositions qu'il ferait parce qu'il
est important aujourd'hui de se
concerter avec les citoyens pour prendre
des décisions pour eux voilà ya une
convergence des luttes
aujourd'hui on le voit au sein de la
mobilisation il ya des familles qui sont
là qui sont présentes
justement et plus de présence policière
finalement qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
qu'est-ce que ça ça ça veut dire
vis-à-vis de ses possibilités
alors déjà dans un premier temps la
convergence avec le climat l'a toujours
été parce que là la première pétition
qui a eu lieu concernant la pétition de
près si la ludo ce qui avait un rappel
aussi sur la transition des carburants
la transition écologique donc scellier
et puis derrière sur le prix des
carburants
donc les taxes qui a été prise
concernant sur un litre d'essence à
chaque fois il ya peu près 70 à 80 % qui
normalement aurait dû resservir à
assortir à pouvoir financer une autre
énergie pour pour la route pour les
transports pour tout ça et puis en fin
de compte on s'est aperçu que c'était
une supercherie l'argent a été versé au
cic eux qui normalement elle même devait
couvrir
les des embauches et maintenir l'emploi
ce qui n'a pas été le cas
donc on s'est aperçu que c'était une
vraie supercherie est effectivement pour
revenir sur la mobilisation ici et
l'encadrement des forces de l'ordre on
peut voir deux poids deux mesures dans
la mesure où je pense quand même que
macron à un petit peu peur de se mettre
à dos toutes ces personnes parce qu'on
sait très bien que ben on peut pas
dissocier le social et l'environnement
et il sait que c'est des futurs
électeurs
toutes ces personnes donc je peux je le
vois pas en train de commencer à
s'attaquer à ce type de population par
rapport à toute la répression qu'il a pu
faire sur nous concernant le social et
on peut voir les mauvais choix qu'il a
pu faire aussi sur l'économie
parce que du coup bah il a plongé il a
il à endetter davantage ce pays et il
est à mon sens ils ont fait des mauvais
choix
beaucoup ont choisi la lutte a répondu à
nos questions
vous l'aurez compris à la convergence
des luttes s est important la
mobilisation déroule pour le moment dans
le calme et dans une ambiance assez un
fait s'ils avaient quelque peu de
présence policière
je vous le disais de nombreuses
personnalités politiques sont également
présentes au sein du cortège des
personnalités politiques qui sont venus
apporter leur soutien à ce mouvement
des personnalités qui qui font partie de
cette tribune qui a été signée par plus
de 230 personnes étaient politiques afin
de réclamer un véritable texte un
véritable projet de loi sur le climat et
surtout qu emmanuel macron tienne ses
engagements un vis-à-vis de cette
convention citoyenne
merci à david pour toutes ces précisions